لا شك ان التغييرات المناخيه باتت تشكل
تهديدا حقيقيا للبشر على كوكب الارض
والتصدي لها اصبح حتميا وحتميا والا فستقع
الكارثه المنظمه العالميه للارصاد الجويه
دقه ناقوس الخطر وحضرت بشكل صريح من ان
التغيور المناخي باتسير بسرعه كارثيه تدمر
البشر وسبل العيش في كل القاره المنظمه
اصدرت تقريرا سنويا تزامنا مع قيمه شرم
الشيخ وصفت فيها وضع المناخ العالمي
بالفوضى المناخيه
تقرير المنظمه الذي يعتمد على من تقدمه
الدول من بيانات بشان المناخ افاد بان
معدلات الحراره عالميا تشتد وشهدت ارتفاعا
عن ما كانت عليه بين عامين 1850 و1900
بمقدار درجه ونصف الدرجه مئويه كما ظهرت
تقرير عن ارتفاع مستوى البحر زاد بمعادل
الضعف عن ما كان عليه في عام 1993
[موسيقى]